en l'absence du célèbre événement
emmanuel macron s'est rendu dans cette
grande exploitation côte-d'orienne
circuits courts vente directe ici les
producteurs ont fait des efforts ils
sont prêts à en faire plus mais
attendent d'être payés en retour
si on s'engage dans une démarche
environnementale que la vue qu'on fait
cet effort là qui est vraiment un bonus
qui soit important et puis significatif
de manière à ce que les fermes qui qui
prennent le pas d'aller dans cette voie
là la récompense de ce travail fait avec
avec du coup un bonus sur le prix à ce
moment là et puis pareil sur la viande
pareil sur tous les produits agricoles
ce mardi emmanuel macron n'apporte pas
de solution immédiate pour régler la
question des prix mais face à ces
inquiétudes le chef de l'état a
réaffirmé son soutien
vous avez nourri le pays dans un moment
on a dû tout fermé il n'y a aucune
fatalité on a réussi la bataille des
trente glorieuses pour nourrir le pays
on réussira celle que j'évoque un
instant qui la bataille de nos
générations depuis 2018
la loi sur l'alimentation doit permettre
une meilleure répartition des revenus
entre les maillons de la chaîne
alimentaire
mais les agriculteurs la justine
efficace ils veulent des mesures
concrètes pour aller plus loin
les agriculteurs ont
fortement besoin le voilà qu'on rémunère
leurs produits à leur juste valeur
on a besoin de visibilité on a besoin de
voix d'engagement de la part de chaque
acteur de chaque maillon de la chaîne
alimentaire pour pour pouvoir sécuriser
l'alimentation et la production de la
ferme france
réponse dans quelques jours c'est au 1er
mars que vont se clôturer les difficiles
négociations commerciales entre
producteurs industriels et la grande
distribution